hello everybody hope they are good the
week has been filled that was her main
target for the past couple of weeks
um we knew that you know even if we were
in this sort of a range here right we
knew that they want to go back to this
week because that's what they always do
they always go back to fill the weeks
okay and you can see that in the four
hour time frame the 50ma we had several
deviations above the 50ma but then price
eventually came lower right as you can
see so that's why also we were expecting
that as long as price couldn't come back
about the 50ma test it as support
okay and then go higher
so as long as they couldn't do this like
you know the several times you can see
even here that they didn't test their
support and they had this red candle
breaking again below it right so as long
as they couldn't do that they were
favored in the state lower prices I was
pretty clear with that all right so we
were favoring the 50 of the week because
uh let me be clear with you guys as long
as they feel at least the 50 of the week
then this week is done for me right and
you can see they fill the 50 so let me
remove that a week okay now what it's
interesting to me is that there is a
still
quite a lot of liquidity
below all right we're gonna go in a
minute to high block Capital I'm gonna
show you these liquidations here right
are 25 400 but we also have this trend
line okay let me show you in the daily
time frame because this is a very
interesting level in the chart all right
you have here
you know these resistance price one here
then we saw a sell-off
okay you can see that then price went
back to it we saw another sell-off so
that was a very strong resistance that
was a key level in the chart and to be
honest if you notice we haven't tested
our support yet right so that's an
interesting Zone to see how price reacts
to okay because if we go all the way
here all right and then we say a bounce
or even a sweep of the lows first all
right so in kind of deviation then we
can even favor higher prices all right
but if in the other hand we see you know
a drop we lose this level then we're
gonna go lower because there is still
quality liquidity here okay you have
this two liquidity pools over here
all right and also in the weekly time
frame
you have
you have a week here right
that will be 100 of the week that will
be the 50 of the week so that will take
you you know between 22k and 20K in my
opinion all right so that's what I'm
telling you guys be aware because
um we can still go lower from here right
but we're gonna go now into lower time
frame right let's try to figure out what
can happen today because you know we're
day Traders that's all that matters to
us all right
um so far what I can see is if we go to
the one hour time frame you want to
notice something quite interesting here
in my opinion these are three tops
patterns or a potential three times
pattern okay we have the first step here
the second tab here
and now uh this could be the third tab
but I'm not sure let me invert the chart
sorry
um is that a third up really
or are we still due to see another tab
here all right
and then price can reverse
so that's what I'm thinking guys all
right I would like to see also we have a
week here yes I mean this week is
filling this week so it doesn't
necessarily need to be filled
that's the role of the weak Village
strategy right or at least that's what I
see in the chart playing out so this
week over here it's not compulsory that
it gets filled all right because it's
filling this previous week uh but still
thinking that we might see
a three tops button all right
um thinking that maybe this is not the
third top it could be okay because if
you see it's at the same level right so
it could be the third top but what I
would like to see is you know fill in
the 50 of this week
all right and then we can go higher
that's what I'm trying to figure it out
again
you know this might have been the third
up that's why I'm currently in a long
position because I don't want to miss
out but it is still possible that we see
another hit to the downside maybe right
at the start of the New York session
the near session starts in a couple of
hours only all right and then from here
a bounce I'm gonna show you now
where
it could be my target okay if you do the
four hour time frame okay we can see
here
our liquidity pool
right
we can see the liquidity pool over there
and we also have the four hour 50ma so I
think eventually it can match maybe to
this liquidity pool and that can be a
very important level in the chart all
right so that's what we're anticipating
we're anticipating today
26 700 ish all right so today I'm not
gonna go into shorts
today I'm going to be looking for wrongs
why because if we also go to the one
hour time frame all right we can see
the today is Thursday
what usually happens on Thursdays I've
been telling you this for quite some
time
it's useful that we can see
midweek reversals all right and that
means that you know you've had here uh
that we can range so that we can finish
this
here all right and then you can see that
we have right at the start of the week a
false move to the upside that goes a
level to twenty seven thousand five
hundred all right then you have all the
week a downtrend
and today's Thursday so today we can
expect a midweek reversal all right
where to well am I opinion is going to
be this soon 26 700. that's going to be
my target why because if you also notice
that's kind of what we left it at the
weekend all right
so that will take us again
to the weekend range and of course you
have you know this liquidity pool the 4
Hour 50ma and also this Zone over here
it was the previous song where we saw a
sell-off all right so why not I think
that we're gonna get here today that
would take us to 26 000
sorry 20 26
let me see
26 732 all right if we are lucky
let me remove all all this chaos here
all right if we are lucky
I mean New York session it starts in a
couple of hours if we are lucky we can
still see
this move here then we can open our
lungs here that's what I'm gonna do
again it's not Financial advice
and then we can see price going again
all the way to the sun uh sometimes I
like to inverse the the chart so I can
see more clearly and again I'm not sure
if this over here was the third top
that's what I'm gonna try to catch today
that move that's what I want to see
today in the channel right so I think
that was quite clear guys
um
we filled the week we're happy I was
telling you guys I don't care about
these drops here all right I'm not happy
until they fill the week
and they've already done it so now I'm
happy crypto is happy now
um if the chart is nice with me today
then
um yes that's what I would like to see
midweek reversal you know I see a clear
false move right to the start of the
week
then all that week we've been dumping
all right and now we like to see a
reversal
okay guys we are in high block Capital
liquidation levels in three months time
frame and this is what I was talking
about there is a lot of liquidity at 25
600 and of course 25 400.
so that's you know a very interesting
zone of Liquidations in the chart now
what I was saying right at the start of
the week was that I think that this is a
rule for liquidity this Bounce from 25
800 to 27k
why because I found a bit suspicious
that
for you know 200 or 400 they didn't hit
all these liquidations instead they left
a massive quick behind a strong bounce
right and in my opinion that was to
induce fomo in the retail Traders okay
so they thought okay that's the dip I
need to buy I need to go long
um I think that was the dip I'm gonna go
along with times 50 times 100 Leverage
and those Traders with high Leverage
they're gonna have their liquidations at
this level 25 400 25 600 I wanna have
electric regions in this Zone
all right so at the end of the week
there was going to be a lot more
Liquidations in this and that there was
before
all right so I mean you can check here
you know this this bars are brighter now
than they were
a couple of weeks ago right
that's because what I'm saying you know
retail goes long their liquidations are
again in this zone so if the market
comes now and hit this level 25 400.
they're gonna hit more liquidations
they're gonna hit this area in a more
efficient way
because the market is about liquidity
and efficiency
okay so that's what I think guys now now
this is a speculation okay though I
think that they're gonna hit this Zone
today I don't think so
because today I'm traveling I made with
reversal okay I'm favoring higher prices
today I'm favoring Longs I might be
wrong with this
you don't need to follow me because this
is not Financial advice just do your own
analysis and then if you have a similar
idea
done me maybe I can you can use my my
analysis as Confluence but nothing else
okay so I think that today we must see
some kind of midweek reversal we like
that zone at 26 700 for today
um
that's what I think now
again this is speculating I don't think
they're gonna hate this song today
tomorrow
I'm not sure probably neither
maybe next week that's why I think okay
because they've been here you're not
playing around this zone for
13 days that's two weeks right so why
not maybe they hold this Zone still
for a couple of days more until maybe
next week that's what I'm thinking start
taking their time they are you know
if today they said uh green candle to 26
700 or 800. there is gonna be you know
more long positions
High leverage with Liquidations in this
zone so still it would be part of their
plan that's what I'm thinking okay so
that's what I think guys be very careful
I hope that you know this video has been
helpful and not before I finish this
video I want to talk about something
else okay really quickly I'm
collaborating with bitjet because I
needed an exchange to trade that doesn't
require kyc because the exchange that I
was trading with in the past is not
asking for kyc so with I could
create an account deposit trade Withrow
all of this without kyc would I find
quite interesting now if you are from
the USA Canada or Singapore you are
gonna need a VPN to open an account or
ask maybe a friend from somewhere else
to open an account for you so you can
log in and we've also come with this
campaign for all of you guys that want
to use the platform and if you log in
with my referral Link in the description
you're gonna get a 15 of trading fees
discount for life also when you sign up
you're gonna get five dollar bonus and
any deposits between two hundred dollars
and a thousand dollars are gonna get a
10 payback that means that if you for
example deposit two hundred dollars
you're gonna get twenty dollars extra or
if you deposit five hundred dollars you
get 50. if you deposit a thousand
dollars you get a hundred
and there are also another campaign here
okay you can check it for higher
deposits okay so for example if you
deposit twenty thousand dollars you're
gonna get 730 extra and also you know if
you deposit even more but you can give
in more rewards but then you also want
to be trading volume but for this
um deposits between two hundred dollars
and a thousand dollars you don't need
trading volume okay do you need to
deposit and then you're gonna get some
money back and what I'm gonna say now in
my opinion is the most interesting part
okay because you guys know that the
trading course is full until July
included it got full very quickly
um what I did was to spare 10 places
okay so there are 10 places there that I
saved for a giveaway okay 10 places for
July so anybody that is registering with
my referral link and depositing at least
a hundred dollars then it's gonna enter
it's gonna participate this giveaway and
can win a slot in the trading course for
free I'm going to announce the 10
winners in five days the 30th of May so
feel free to participate you still have
five days to participate and I wish you
good luck and of course guys thank you
so much for watching the video and I'll
see you soon